ce matin eric coquerel des [ __ ]
soumis est devenu sur le fil président
de la commission des finances une
première dans l'histoire du parti de
jean luc mélenchon il y à une nouvelle
vague de co vide nous sommes dans une
phase d'ascension du nombre de cas qui
est ascension assez nette je compte
rapidement effectivement qu'on voit un
peu la différence avec avec
les quinquennat passé où en gros c'était
souvent
des choses des présidents qui était un
peu compatible avec les visions de la
majorité pic de contamination va être
probablement plutôt faut être prudent
mais plutôt pour fin juillet et puis
ensuite les choses vont probablement se
calmer pour une série de raisons on a
préféré un dogmatique incompétents qui
va avoir des menaces planant en
permanence sur les grandes entreprises
de notre pays en pleine crise en plus
international c'était quand même d'une
intelligence incroyable car la
commission des finances contrôler le
budget de l'état et son application mais
elle peut aussi ouvrir des commission
denquête à ce titre son président peut
demander au ministère de l'économie les
déclarations fiscales de n'importe
quelle entreprise ou particulier c'est
l'extrême gauche de l'esam gosses à la
tête de cette commission qui est une
commission extrêmement sensible est un
signal qui est un signal inquiétant pour
l'avenir les républicains portent une
responsabilité intégrale qui par un
système de maintien de candidats ont
fait élire le pire du pire monsieur
coquerel un kiné le pire du pire ah oui
c'est pas la gauche monsieur coquerel un
cr l'extrême gauche anti capitaliste
c'est cette présidence cette commission
continue à être un lieu où on débat plus
du fond que de forme du buzz ou des
choses comme ça bruno le maire à bercy à
a lancé une mise en garde aux
entreprises qui feraient des profits sur
le dos de l'inflation et voilà vous
voyez ces chiffres à qui progresse
considérablement nous avons des gens qui
ont spéculé sur la guerre et aujourd'hui
vous avez des gens qui font beaucoup
d'argent sur la guerre
on appelle ça des profiteurs de guerre
quand je le vois dans des sommets
internationaux à davos on a l'impression
d'avoir un grand humaniste un justicier
on aimerait bien avoir le même à la
maison mais quand il revient c'est plus
le même en cinq ans des manuels mâcon
les premières fortunes françaises ont
triplé la moitié des hausses demandées
ne sont pas transparentes elles sont
suspectes et d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien
que les députés une fois qu'ils aient
fini leur négociation pour les
représentations à l'assemblée nationale
ou au sénat j'aimerais bien que les
députés ouvrent une commission d 4 sur
les origines de l'inflation je suis
attali a décidé de porter plainte il a
décidé de porter plainte pour
provocation à la haine et à la
discrimination la question aujourd'hui
c'est comment on fait pour que on n'est
pas je le répète certains qui se gavent
ans et qui ne laisse que les miettes
d'un monsieur qui travaillent dans son
enfance pour savoir d'abord dans quelles
conditions de ce dessin a été effectué
pour connaître aussi l'identité de son
auteur puisque pour l'instant évidemment
comme dans toute cette sphère
complotistes le dessin est anonyme tout
ça c'est des magouilles d'appareils il
n'a pas fallu dix jours pour que le
régime des partis remplace le
parlementarisme céderait nous avons
besoin de plus de femmes aux postes de
pouvoir si poutine était une femme ce
qui n'est évidemment pas mais s'il était
je ne pense vraiment pas qu'il se serait
lancé dans sont guère folie machiste
l'invasion et de violence comme il l'a
fait dans un contexte de pandémie et que
donc il faut prendre ses précautions une
pandémie de racisme une pandémie
d'antisémitisme une pandémie
d'islamophobie et que donc dans
l'intérêt de la santé de tous j'appelle
les français et particulièrement le
président la république et ses amis à ne
pas serrer la main au rassemblement
national si vous voulez un exemple
parfait de masculinité toxiques c'est ce
qui te fait en ukraine actuellement de
mon point de vue je reste fidèle aux
principes face aux rassemblements
nationalistes
j'aimerais rappeler les événements de
l'histoire moderne - l'ancienne première
ministre britannique margaret thatcher a
décidé de lancer une offensive contre
l'argentine pour le contrôle des îles
malouines wang